the things we did when our kids were  little  we didn't have much money and we wanted  to make christmas last longer so  we would  wrap each kid's presents in a certain  color of wrapping paper and then instead  of putting their name on the wrapping  paper we would send them on a scavenger  hunt so you can see  i put all of the different clues of all  of the places they have to go and this  year because our kids were older  they actually had 40 clues they had to  find  and they all have to work together and  at the end of the scavenger hunt is a  directory that tells them whose paper is  which colors and that's how they know  which presents to open